andrew coburn looks at the rise of
drones and the evolution of their use by
the military
during this event he reads transcripts
from actual drone strikes and describes
the roles that different participants
play
this is about an hour and contains
language that some viewers may find
defensive
there you
go uh
i'm rick mcarthur the publisher of
harper's magazine not a waiter on break
uh i'm delighted to welcome you here to
another in a continuing series of events
sponsored by harper's and book culture
on columbus which is located in the
heart
of manhattan's upper west side
and is rapidly becoming a neighborhood
institution
you will note that this is not a chain
store or a citibank branch
which means that we really need your
patronage to thrive and so far the
support of our customers has been
remarkable and we're grateful for it
it's my great pleasure tonight to
introduce andrew coburn who is the
author of the just published kill chain
the rise of the high-tech assassins
i like doing this for two reasons
uh first as publisher of harper's i'm
lucky to have andrew as our washington
editor a role that he performs
brilliantly at least four times a year
with pieces of a quality that you simply
can't find anywhere else these days
andrew is a
very rare combination
of outraged journalist
and studious craftsmen
who never lets his anger get in the way
of scrupulous accuracy and well-written
storytelling
what always strikes me about andrew's
work is the great amount of detail
rendered in sentences that enliven
rather than way down their subject
this talent is very much in evidence
in the april issue of harper's magazine
in his piece about the history of
corruption
and shall we say loan sharking at
citibank
i'm so proud to be publishing this
article that i rushed early copies here
that i hope you'll buy
right after you've bought kill chain
well i'm gonna let andrew explain his
thesis
but i can't resist reading a brief
passage from this book
that i think captures the essence of the
story
and the deeply disturbing approach to
modern warfare practiced by the pentagon
and the executive branch
kill chain as you may know is a an
expose of the remote control
drone and missile program that nowadays
sucks up such an immense amount of money
and thought in washington
but it's also a history of the peculiar
american obsession with assassination
and with systematized supposedly
sanitized military tactics
an obsession that works itself out
at a dangerous remove from reality on
the ground
that this obsession
is is delusional and self-defeating
should have been proven finally by our
defeat in vietnam
but it lives on today
seemingly stronger than ever
but i couldn't resist this because as a
reporter reporter this this this is a
lot harder to get than you than you may
realize
um
andrew andrews describing
a meeting between
i guess you could call him a kind of
internal whistleblower tom christie
who has actually tested the drones the
predator drones and figured out that
they're highly inaccurate in fact uh
overwhelmingly inaccurate only about 21
percent hit their targets
in their in their tests in nevada
but he's up against the
military-industrial complex in the form
of
a um um
i fear what her name is it's a it's a uh
and she's known as the dragon the dragon
lady of procurement at the pentagon
darlene julian
who is the debt the principal deputy
under secretary of the air force
and um
she would eventually be sentenced to a
nine-month prison term for corrupt
dealings with the boeing corporation
but on that october morning when uh she
went in to confront christie
uh to to to complain about this uh uh
report that he'd written
about the inaccuracy of the drones
she was still much very i'm quoting now
much feared for commanding role in
negotiating prices in multi-billion
dollar contracts
the pentagon building was still smoking
from the devastating impact of american
airlines flight 11 on 9 11
when dreon marched into christie's third
floor office with as christie later
related to me quote four or five
sycophantic generals trailing behind her
unquote
not known for diplomacy she came
straight to the point
what the [ __ ] is this she shouted at the
testing officer office director
what do you mean sending out this
[ __ ] report saying the predator
doesn't work
who is the [ __ ] [ __ ] that wrote
this report
i'm going to ream him a new [ __ ]
[ __ ]
unquote
now that is the voice of the military
industrial complex
uh
in the 21st century
anyway uh christy is unfazed he reports
hold on have you found anything have you
found anything in this report that's
wrong
or no admitted the official but couldn't
you at least take the bit out about
quote not operationally suitable
uh unquote out of the cover letter
all president were well aware that this
was as far as most officials would ever
read
christie gave no ground the letter and
report stood
but it didn't matter
washington was already entranced by the
notion of killing people at a distance
anyway bravo
andrew coburn
well thank you rick
thanks very much rick i am i'm bowled
over by your very kind introduction um
and you must have broken the
four-letter
barrier at c-span i think by now but uh
together we did it
okay i'm going to go back i'm going to
start by reading a um
what is it part of the book which is a
a uh a description of an actual drone
strike um which uh um
is the most com it's
it's it's the fullest okay i can't i
think you you'll see because it uh
it contains the actual all the
communications between all the various
perpetrators of the drone strike the
pilots in um
in nevada and uh
and the people on the ground in
afghanistan so without further ado
a cold february dawn in 2010 two small
fsuvs and a four-door pickup truck
headed down a dirt road in the mountains
of southern afghanistan
they had set out soon after midnight
traveling cross-country to reach highway
one the country's principal praised road
which would lead them to kandahar and
north to kabul crammed inside were more
than 30 men women and children four of
them younger than six
everyone knew one another for all came
from the same cluster of mountain
villages roughly 200 miles southwest of
kabul
many of the men unemployed and destitute
were on their way to iran in hopes of
work
others were shopkeepers heading to the
capital to buy supplies or students
returning to school
the women carried turkeys gifts for the
relatives they would stay with in kabul
a number were hazaras an ethnic minority
of shia muslims who the taliban treated
with unremitting cruelty whenever they
had the opportunity
now they're in western uruzgan province
taliban country and therefore very
dangerous for them but they risked the
short cusp shortcut because they were
short on gas
they met no other cars and little food
foot traffic the world around them must
have seemed empty but it was not
unbeknownst to them they were
unbeknownst to them they were being
watched and their every movement even
the wolf from their bodies transmitted
across the globe
as the ramshackle vehicles one of them
kept breaking down and another blue
attire clattered along people they would
never meet conferred across oceans and
continents as to who they were where
they were going what they were carrying
and whether they should live or die
unwittingly the little group was driving
toward an operational detachment alpha
as u.s special forces patrol patrol
dropped in with the supporting force of
afghan soldiers soon after midnight to
attack the nearby village of cod
such raids were routine in afghanistan
planned and executed by the semi mythic
special operations command that
specializes in the pursuit and
elimination of high value targets
someone thought this operation important
enough to give it the code name
operation noble justice
sunday february 21st 4 12
am pilot of mq-1 predator callsign
kirk97
we are eyes on the first vehicle
observing to try and pid on the packs in
the open standby for movement on the
second
the 27-foot long predator drone was
circling at fourteen thousand feet below
its belly protruded a sensor ball
carrying a variety of cameras including
an infrared video that picked up the
warmth thrown off by the vehicles and
passengers two and a half miles below
almost in an instant but not quite the
images flashed across the world of twin
screens inside a metal box roughly the
side of a shipping container at creech
air force base in the nevada desert
facing the screen sat kirk 97 a pilot
guiding the drone by remote control
beside hims had a sensor operator who
guided the cameras and weapons targeting
laser
another room sat a third member of the
crew the mission intelligence
coordinator who was watching the same
video images
the pictures had audiences elsewhere
herbert air force base in the florida
panhandle is headquarters of air force
special operations command and home to
one station of the vast but little known
global network referred to as the
distributed common ground system dcgs
this is a central nervous system of
drone warfare funneling collating and
sharing the unimaginable quantities of
imagery and electronic information
collected by air force drones and
reconnaissance planes around the globe
in theory anyone in any part of the
system has access to any information
that's been fed into the syst into the
system wherever they are
thus it was that the images captured by
the predator were being watched at
albert by a dedicated team a mini
bureaucracy of young men and women
each with specialized tasks
an overall charge was an intelligence
tactical coordinator supervising two
screeners the chief screener civilian on
contract from a major defense
corporation heavily involved in drone
operations outrank the second screener a
junior air force officer who happened to
be her husband
also present were two full motion video
analysts while one watched the screen
the other typed products conclusions
drawn from the imagery which were then
passed to the screeners for onward
transmission by uh
to the mission intelligence coordinator
sitting in his trailer in nevada
another analyst tasked with generating
relevant geographical information for uh
made up the complement
the ultimate beneficiary of all these
complex arrangements was a sergeant
attached to the raiding party
known as a joint terminal attack
controller he was responsible for
communicating via radio with any and all
air support including the predator and
relaying orders and intelligence to and
from the young captain commanding the
party calling himself jaguar 25 the
sergeant was the force's only link with
the team in nevada which in turn was the
sole link with the screeners in florida
almost as soon as the raiding party
disembarked from their helicopters
shortly after midnight someone out in
the darkness had switched on a handheld
radio and broadcast a general call to
arms
they are here he said let us get all the
mujahideen together and defend this
place
it was a simple uncomplicated excitation
addressed to no one in particular and
audible to anyone with a radio
utterly unlike the assorted esoteric
systems employed by the us forces
americans listening in were bemused by
their enemies unconcerned for
eavesdropping and indeed the taliban
summons if that's what it was was
overheard by a host of u.s military
intelligence posts on the ground and in
the air
accordingly the word was passed to look
out for enemy reinforcements
two vehicles in tandem the pickup and
one suv lumbering into the area easily
fit that picture and suspicions hardened
when they and another suv flash lights
at each other before continuing on in
and together in the direction of the
patrol as it waited for daylight
4 15 am
mission intelligence coordinator see if
you can zoom in on that guy because he's
like pilot why did he just leave there
is that a [ __ ] rifle
sensor operator maybe just a warm spot
from where he's been sitting
pilot i was hoping we could make out a
rifle never mind
sensor the only way i've ever been able
to see a rifle is if they move them
around when they're holding them with
muzzle flashes out or slinging them
across their shoulders
drone operators are not in immediate
contact with the real world literally so
thanks to the phenomenon known as
latency a reference to the time it takes
for information to make its way from the
drone to a satellite 22 000 miles up in
space down again to a drone ground
station in ramstein germany switching to
a fiber optic cable through which it
travels across western europe the
atlantic ocean and the continental
united states before reaching nevada and
the screen in the pilot's trailer
as the electronic pulses are split
reunited and buffered for the assembly
into packages pending their dispatch to
the next way station microsecond delays
steadily accumulate
it means that the scene on a pilot's
screen is out of date usually two
seconds but sometimes as much as five
seconds
as the crew reacts to what they are
seeing moving their controls to send an
instruction to the aircraft they're
flying
that signal in turn takes two up to five
seconds to deliver
this time lapse is why drone takeoffs
and landings must be handled by a
separate team of pilots stationed close
to the runway so they can see the planes
they are flying in real time
potential targets on the ground are
aware of the delay yemeni members of
al-qaeda reported in 2011 that when they
hear a drone overhead they move around
as fast as possible
nor do the pictures themselves
necessarily always bear close
resemblance to the world as the rest of
us see it and sometimes i quote no
better than looking at google earth
through a straw as one veteran room
of the drone operations uh told me
thus for most of the time the convoy was
under watch the sensor could only focus
on two of the three vehicles at a time
if the operator zoomed out ever even
slightly the already imperfect
resolution was lost
imagery became less precise it was dust
in the air the drone was too high or a
dusk or dawn when both infrared and
daylight
cameras lose efficiency or when the
sensor operator could not focus properly
the video as received by troops on the
ground that night in aura's gun was even
poorer described by one of them as crap
full of static and crackling
4 24 am jaguar 25
what are we looking for is a quick
reaction force we believe we may have a
high level taliban commander
pilot
wouldn't surprise me if this is one of
their important guys just watching from
a distance you know what i mean
then came an unwelcome message from
florida
4 37 am
mission intelligence coordinator
screener said at least one child near
suv sensor [ __ ] where
send me a [ __ ] still i don't think
they have kids at this hour i know
they're shady but come on
pilot at least one child really
listing him as a man military age male
that means he's guilty censor well maybe
a teenager but i haven't seen anything
that looks that short granted they're
all grouped grouped together uh
grouped together but mission
intelligence coordinator they're
reviewing
pilot yeah review that [ __ ] why didn't
he say possible child why are they so
quick to call [ __ ] kids just but not
to call [ __ ] a rifle
just as the sun rose above the mountains
the convoy halted on a riverbank and
many of the passengers got out to the
watchers the pictures revealed something
ominous
5 10 a.m pilot they're praying
censor this is definitely it this is
their force praying i mean seriously
that's what they do
mission intelligence coordinator they're
going to do something
nefarious what all the adults in the
party including the six or seven women
got out when the convoy stopped at the
river but to the infrared camera high
above and so too to the watchers far
away the men and women were merely
indistinguishable blobs
since the party was presumptively one of
taliban enforcements no one thought to
ponder their gender
an hour later the vehicles which have
been heading south toward the american
ground unit turned off in a different
direction this led them ultimately 12
miles away from the americans on the
ground an indication that whoever they
were they most likely had no hostile
intent
nevertheless the predator pilot assessed
this as merely a flanking maneuver to
get behind the troops and cut off their
escape route
6 59 a.m pilot
can't wait till this actually happens
with all this coordination and [ __ ]
sensor operator and mission intelligence
coordinate together murmuring yeah
through though far removed from the
scene of the action drone crews see
themselves in the same martial tradition
as the fighter pilots of an earlier age
down to the flight suits they were to
work the combat stress their report
experiencing not to mention the combat
pay in awards they have successfully
demanded
their trailer chatter that night echoed
that of combat crews who were flying
through a battle zone for real only once
in a while does the record reveal that
they were in fact firmly on the ground
seven seven and a half thousand miles
away
seven eleven am sensor operator
well sir would you mind if i took a
bathroom break real quick
pilot no not a tall dude
the crew spoke a language almost
incomprehensible to outsiders so laden
with acronyms that plain english was
often supplanted but that night's
conversation showed that the military
jargon like the two second video delay
imposed another layer between them and
the reality on the ground
any mam military age male became by
definition an enemy fighter irrespective
of age and therefore a legitimate target
positive identification bid is an
official u.s military term for someone
positively identified as an immediate
hostile threat and therefore a
legitimate target
as investigators subsequently discovered
the term meant entirely different things
to different people
7 38 am
pilot our screeners are currently
calling 21 mams no females and two
possible children our copy
jaguar 25 roger and when we say children
are we talking teenagers or toddlers
censor i would say about 12 not toddlers
something more toward adolescents or
teens pilot yeah adolescence
7 40 am pilot our screener identified
only one adolescent so that's one double
digit age range high copy
jaguar 25 we'll pass that along on the
ground commander to the ground force
commander but like i said 12 to 13 years
old with a weapon is just as dangerous
sensor oh we agree yeah
pilot hey good copy on that we
understand and agree
8 35 a.m pilot all right so the plan is
man uh we're gonna watch this thing go
down and when they run out of ammunition
that's some helicopters who are also on
the tendons we can play cleanup sensor
initial plan without seeing how they
break up follow the largest group pilot
yeah sounds good when it all comes down
everybody's everybody's running in their
separate direction i don't care if you
just follow one guy you know what you
know
like whatever you decide to do i'm with
you on it so long as you keep somebody
that we can shoot in the field of view
i'm happy
uh the first missile from the lead
helicopter who uh scored a direct hit on
the pickup killing
instantly killing 11 passengers the two
following suvs jerked or halt and the
passengers began frantically to scramble
out the second missile hit their rear
most vehicle but in the engine block
which absorbed enough of the blast to
allow some of the passengers to escape
four died immediately the third missile
missed the middle's suv barely with the
blast blowing out the rear window as
passengers bailed out as a matter of
routine the attackers pursued those
squirters their word for people flying a
strike fleeing a strike with 2.75 inch
rockets though all of these missed
then someone noticed something strange
the people who escaped were not running
8 52 am
sensor that's weird
pilot
can't tell what the [ __ ] they're doing
safety observer are they wearing burqas
sensor that's what it looks like
pilot they were all pids as males no
female in the group
sensor that guy looks like he's working
wearing jewelry and stuff like a like a
girl but he ain't if he's a girl he's a
big one
despite the sensor operators hopeful
theory these were not taliban in drag
but women who had scrambled out and were
waving their brightly coloured skulls at
the circling helicopters which
eventually ceased fire
23 people had been killed including two
boys daud three years old and mortaza
four
eight men one woman one woman and three
children aged between five and fourteen
were wounded many of them severely
9 10 am
mission intelligence coordinator
screener said there weren't any women
earlier
censor what are these they were in the
middle vehicle mission intelligence
coordinator women and children
the conversation in the nevada trailer
was losing its previously jaunty tone as
mams became mothers and adolescents
turned back into children
9 15 a.m
pilot it looks like uh one of those in
the uh bright gob may be carrying a
child as well
censor younger than that younger than an
adolescent to me
safety observer well
no way to tell man censor no way to tell
from here
so um
just going to move on to um
actually that same uh the following year
describing a dinner um at the uh
it's an annual dinner held by the um
uh
the
the um
cia
officers memorial foundation which is
raises money to um
uh to support the families of those who
died in action and that's a big jamboree
attended by um
well as you'll see a lot of defense
corporations
who pay for tables and so forth
decades earlier richard helms the cia
director for whom the event was named
would customarily customarily refer to
the defense contractors who pressured
him to spend his budget on their wares
as those bastards
such disdain for commerce in the world
of spooks was now long gone as
distrement demonstrated by the corporate
sponsorship of the tables jammed into
the grand ballroom that evening
the executives many of whom had passed
through through the revolving door from
government service were there to rub
shoulders with old friends and current
partners
it was totally garish one attendee told
me afterwards seemed like every arms
manufacturer in the country had taken a
table everyone was doing business right
and left
in the decades since 9 11 the cia had
been regularly blighted by scandal
revelations of torture renditions secret
black site prisons bogus intelligence to
justify the invasion of iraq ignored
signs of the impending 911 attacks but
such unwholesome realities found no echo
in the this comradely gathering
even george tenet the cia director who
had presided over all of the
aforementioned scandals was greeted with
heartfelt affections by erstwhile
colleagues as he along with almost every
other living cia director stood to be
introduced by master of ceremonies john
mclaughlin a former deputy director
himself deeply complicit in the iraq
fiasco
each with the exception of stansfield
turner still bitterly resented for
downsizing the enemy post-vietnam
received ringing applause but none more
than the knights honoree former cia
director and then then current secretary
of defense robert m gates
although gates had left the cia earlier
18 years before he was very much the
father figure of the institution and a
mentor to the intelligence chieftains
active and retired who cheered him so
fervently that night at the ritz carlton
he had climbed through the ranks of the
national security bureau bureaucracy
with a ruthless determination all too
evident to those around him
ray mcgovern his supervisor in his first
agency post as an analyst with the
intelligence director at sauron soviet
foreign policy branch recalls writing in
an efficiency report that the young
man's quote evident and all-consuming
ambition is a disruptive influence in
the branch
gates's successful 91 confirmation of
cihe vote much so so colleagues assessed
a diligent work behind the scenes on the
part of the senate intelligence
committee's staff director george tenet
in 1993 tenet moved on to be director
for intelligence programs on the clinton
white house national security staff in
which capacity he came to know and
esteem john brennan
a mid-level and hitherto undistinguished
cia analyst assigned to brief white
house staffers
tenet liked brennan so much that when he
himself moved to the cia's deputy
director in 1995 he had the briefer
appointed station chief in riyadh an
important position normally reserved for
someone with actual operational
experience
in this sensitive post brennan worked
tirelessly to avoid irritating his saudi
hosts showing reluctance for example to
press them for osama bin laden's bio
biographical details when asked to do so
by the bin laden unit back at the
headquarters because he said it would
irritate the saudis
exiting government service in 2005
brennan spent the next three years
heading the analysis corporation
obscured extremely profitable
intelligence contractor engaged in
preparing terrorist watch lists for the
government for the government work for
which he was paid 763 000
in 2008 alone
among the useful relationships he had
cultivated over the years was well
connected democrat anthony lake a former
national security adviser to bill
clinton who recommended him to
presidential candidate barack obama
meeting for the first time after obama's
election victory the pair bonded
immediately with obama quote following
finishing brennan's sentences by one
account
among their points of whole-hearted
agreement was the merit of a surgical
approach to terrorist threats the need
to target the mess quote the nes
the mestasticizing disease without
destroying the surrounding tissue as
brennan put it for which drones in their
help our missiles seem the ideal tools
obama was initially balked in his desire
to make brennan cia director because the
ladder's all too close association with
the agency's torture program
so instead the new president made him
his assistant for counter-terrorism and
homeland security with an office down
the hall from the oval office
two years into the administration
everyone in the ritz-carlton bill room
knew that the bulky irishman was the
most powerful man in us intelligence as
the custodian of the president's kill
list
on which the chief executive and former
constitutional law professor insist on
re insisted on reserving the last word
making his final selections for
execution as at regularly choose
scheduled tuesday afternoon meetings
you know
our president has his brutal side a cia
source cognizant of obama's involvement
observed to me at the time
now along with the other 600 diners at
the helm's dinner brennan listened
attentively as gates rose to accept the
coveted award for exemplary service to
the nation and the central intelligence
agency
after paying due tribute to previous
honorees as well as his pride in being
part of the cia family
gates spoke movingly of a recent and
particularly tragic incidence of cia
sacrifice the seven men and women killed
by a suicide bomber at an agency base
forward operating base chapman in host
afghanistan in 2009
all present bowed their heads in silent
tribute
keith then moved on to a more upbeat
topic when first he arrived at the
pentagon in 2007 he said he had found
deep-rooted resistance to new technology
among
fly boys with silk scarves still wedded
to venerable traditions of fighter plane
combat but all that he informed his
wrapped audience had changed factories
were working
night and day night and day to turn out
the vital weapons for the fight against
terrorism from so from now on he
concluded his voice rising the watch
word is drones baby drones
the applause was long and loud
um might
[Applause]
pause there
my voice rest if anyone has any
questions
obama gave us obama gave his famous
speech about how we're going to be more
careful now and no civilians will ever
be killed and so forth what's your
statement of what's happened since that
he gave that speech well they're still
calling i mean he he referred in that
speech i think to the you know because
our weapons were aimed with precise
precision um
you know and according to brennan of
course they never killed any civilians
at all um
so you know so
it's what you consider a civilian i mean
in their eyes um you know a 13 year old
child
is is not a civilian as a military-aged
male and therefore deserving death the
thing is they do you know i'm sure obama
yes it's a horrible embarrassment they
hate it when they kill uh
uh killed children but um since that
speech there's been a number of
occasions particularly in yemen where
they've killed you know they've
unquestionably killed civilians um
in pakistan as well i'm not so sure
about that but in pakistan
they don't really know uh i mean in in
because of the nature of push to in
society with women and
and girl you know infant
baby girl babies kept sort of a wave and
the neighbors don't know their names or
know how as many they're there you just
couldn't you you couldn't know how many
people you'd killed
so
it's basically a sort of protestation i
think that you know obama i'm sure if
you put a lie detector test on him he'd
say
you know absolutely you know he hates
the idea of killing civilians but the
fact is with this kind of warfare
dependent of the kind of intelligence
they do it on which is
almost wholly electronic um
with maybe a little input from some very
questionable sources and very partial
sources as i explained in the book um
it's inevitable that you're going to
kill civilians and they have done they
can you know whatever obama says
anyone else
um
hey
is there more
is there any data that shows that
there's more uh
killing of civilians
using drones than there is conventional
methods of catastrophe that were raining
on the middle east um
i mean there's some spectacular ones
which have been done by uh
mandelph i mean like in um
in 2009 for instance b1 bomber
bombed what they felt absolutely assured
was a taliban concentration in uh
in afghanistan and killed
uh
somewhere between 80 and 120 civilians
um in one go
um i mean
i should say you know although we're
talking you know people particularly
fascinated by drones in a way there's
you know there's a very narrow line
between drones which you know operate by
remote control
you know by someone sitting half a world
away and for instance the b1 bomber the
operator there the person who presses
the button and you know aims the
the weapons he's sitting in a metal box
inside the plane looking at a video
screen
so maybe the signal gets a bit quicker
but i think really there's not a huge
amount of difference i mean it's the
same
distance you know one removed from
reality um
where they um but to answer your
question i think you know i think
just because the nature of the weapons
being dropped um
you know a banned bomber can kill more
people in one go
um
the thing is about drones is apart from
you know the severe people they actually
kill that's the whole effect on a
society because of their omnipresence
you know in waziristan you could and in
yemen and other places you can hear them
all the time and i should say in gaza
too um
you know the constant buzzing and so it
seems to have a much more sort of
traumatizing effect on the society
because they know at any moment you know
that things there you can hear it in any
moment a missile could come
out of the sky and blow people away it's
why children in
in pakistan in the northwest frontier
you're known not to play when it's a
sunny day because the drones have good
visibility then you know they go out and
play when it's cloudy uh that's why
people don't gather for sort of they
used to
in that society the main sort of
gatherings would be for weddings and
funerals but people sort of are scared
of going to those now because you know
many of those have been hit funerals are
particularly popular kind of target for
drone strikes
um so if you added up the numbers it's
hard to tell um
so it's you know because mostly we can't
in so many cases
civilians i mean i did a story of
bahabas a couple years ago about a a
strike on uh which was from a b1 on a
a fire compound in afghanistan
where the first of all the planes that
were initially dispatched the two pilots
into 810 fighter planes they looked
because they they're equipped to
actually look directly at the ground
they said this this is an innocent
family though it's a farm family taking
in the animals at night
uh b1 up above there so they refused to
bomb and said no we're going home
uh a b1 up above said well we're happy
to do it and they dropped the bombs and
um
blew away seven seven people the parents
and five children
but that was not that was classified as
a successful operation actually the
classified record was actually
stolen disappeared from the piles
because they've been embarrassed about
it but initially questioned about it
they said yeah we've blown away
absolutely seven terrorists so it's a
it's a um
it's it's a difficult thing to assess um
in i spit so you know bombs yes until do
have killed more people in one go but
it's the steady insidious sort of drip
drip drip of the drones that uh
i think is is more horrifying in a way
go ahead sorry um
it strikes me that the the
the instigators for this violence the
white house for example obama they're
still
removed
from the actions themselves and i wonder
if you feel they're
they're more removed they sense
themselves more distant and more capable
of this kind of directing these kind of
killings because of their drone strikes
because
for for me and i think for most of us in
the public we're so far removed from the
violence anyway and so far removed from
even recognizing we've got veterans and
soldiers among us we've asked to go and
do these things on the ground
perhaps
in obama's in the cia's mind there there
there isn't that much more difference
because they're drones
there's still uh a great deal of
different
distance between the conceptual
killing that they're doing whether
they're sending troops to go do it by
hand-to-hand combat to stab some in the
neck or or whether their distance
is
drones
well i think the insidious thing that's
really happened and
very much thanks to drones is they think
they think they're in touch
you know obama you know the famous
picture of the night of the oba you know
the osama bin laden raid they're all all
the white house staff you think of you
know they took the afternoon off to
watch the uh
to watch you know to watch this um
what's their enemy being killed um
so they're all watching a video and so
they all and they were you know it was
taken from a kind of in a very great
picture um but it was taken from um
particular kind of stealth drone that
was high above the
uh avadabad um and they all um so they
you know they feel that they're in real
time they're all so excited they're
watching live tv and that's happening
more and more not just for the president
but for the senior commanders
that it gives them the illusion of being
close to the action in a way that they
felt they might not have had if they
just send troops off and are relying on
written reports or something like that
this can actually you know generals four
star generals can now play lou you know
platoon leaders in a part by they are in
direct control they think
um but of course as you know for all
sorts of reasons including some which i
just talked about when i was reading um
they're not in contact it gives you an
entirely false picture
um first of all it's out of date um
because of latency and you know the
picture is actually very
much more blurry than they have you
believe and it's
you know there's no context so i think
that the insidious that is the insidious
thing this general
increasing distancing from
from from reality from the real picture
um
as exemplified by that um
you know strike on the farmhouse i was
just talking about whether you know
people who could see the ground said
there's nothing there and the people who
couldn't blow away the family and i
think that's happening on an ever larger
scale um
you know obama thinks it's this weird
thing that he he thinks that if he
actually looks at you know he has a sort
of book with um the pictures of all the
you know that week's intended you know
people who are recommended for death
which is prepared by this sort of huge
bureaucracy um
and he goes through the pictures and he
says you know him or
obviously i haven't been there but i
mean it seems to say him him not him
and he thinks he's controlling the whole
thing then i mean the fact that it's all
being fed to him
i think it's quite interesting that the
intelligence people have given him the
illu you know they've roped him in so
he's culpable i mean he's he's been very
much involved so um
i don't know it's kind of long-winded
answered your question but i i that to
me is one of the most basic points of
what's wrong with what's going on
this illusion of adjacency illusion of
illusion of contact
if i can find the passage i'd like to
read another uh
one more question go ahead
andrew is anybody in congress trying to
do anything about this oh sure um
[Music]
yes they are you know there's um not
enough of them i mean it's generally
very popular in congress i mean there
are a few uh
uh
i mean one of the most eloquent sort of
denouncers of all this is rand paul um
who actually made the most eloquent
statement that when it came out that um
you know they released the legal this
rather sort of jim crack
extremely squishy
legal opinion on which they
which they used to give themselves
permission to
to kill an american citizen
uh
ran you know
most of congress of most of you know
washington so sat very quiet for this i
mean it was absolutely outrageous that
they had some tame lawyer who they
subsequently made a federal judge uh you
know run up an opinion saying it's
absolutely okay and it was sort of
cobbled together
opinion it sort of took a bit from
israel the israeli you know the the the
the legal justification the israelis
have
blowing people away which of course they
do in quantity um
and that was slapped in and it was rand
paul who came up with a very eloquent
statement saying this is completely
outrageous the president of the united
states that has the power has given
himself the power to kill anyone he
wants any time
which is not the cutscene you know there
are a few others barbara michaels who's
um
barbara lee sorry who's a
congresswoman from berkeley who was the
only member of congress to vote against
the original authorization
authorization for the use of military
force
um on which all these wars since then
have been based
um
so i you you know congress has some have
routinely redeemed the reputation of
congress but even you meet a liberal you
know there's a friend of ours who's a
liberal senator who's on the
intelligence committee and you raised
this with him i love the drone program
it's so clean it's so precise you know
they it it gives the liberals a letter
but at least we're not you know carpet
bombing them but but we're destroying
societies
so that's really the situation
um
if you say give me a second of course
the um
i'm going to talk about in um
the essence i mean part of the sort of
keep core point of my book is the uh
this book is the um
the whole notion of that you know that
assassinating people picking off top
leaders is really um the way to gain
victory and
a laudable thing to do
and you know a lot of people say well
maybe that's not true and
people have hunches but
until now i don't think anyone's
produced a um
uh printed uh
explanation of what how we know that's
not true there have actually been
an empirical study it's only one of two
someone did one about israeli strikes
which wasn't it was the data wasn't as
hard but uh
this is a study done um in iraq by
actually someone i know a very
interesting analyst called rex revolo
former fighter pilot who was attached to
a secret in military intelligence cell
in uh in iraq and he
uh he started to investigate this policy
the strategy of
basically on which the whole war was
based of picking off enemy
leaders and i ah this comes after a
passage when i'm talking about all the
all the completely and other ineffective
technological fixes they tried to find
to
for ieds for um homemade bombs
um there was however no mistaking who
controlled the principal strategy for
defeating the ied it was evident even in
the furniture
most of the equipment around the base
was pretty beat up according to one of
those tens of thousands of americans who
passed through its heavily guarded gates
of the military headquarters camp
camp victory during the years of the
occupation
one single story a building however
close to odiona's office
was different it was different though
you walked in there and everything was
brand new remembers a visitor they had
the most up-to-date computers big
servers nice big plasma screens in full
working order on the walls you can tell
it had priority
this was the home of the high value
targeting cell a counterpoint to the
cell counterpart to the cell in the
pentagon that attracts saddam and before
him milosevic here analysts tracked
individuals on nsa manhuntless while
others comb through reports from units
around iraq for sightings of the wanted
men or others to be added to the wanted
men or others to be added to the joint
priorities effects list the jpel a
constantly refreshed master list of
targets
listed for elimination
all around iraq and afghanistan every
unit maintained its own list of high
value targets also known as high value
in individuals each death or capture
dutifully recorded in the situ cigax as
the situation reports were called for
example a may 5th 2006 report on the
shooting of allah
spotted from a us army observation post
and then shot as he tried to escape by
car was summarized at 8 10
an a 3 187 op engaged and killed one of
their battalion hbis in the salah deen
province in samara and then a lot of
long lists of code words
for the high value target industry the
benefits of hunting down the leaders of
the ied networks appeared self-evident
as had assassinating hitler patrice
lumumba or pablo escobar in years gone
by
since the elimination of formerly
critical formerly critical nodes such as
saddam and zarqawi had paid little
dividend the target list was ever
expanding as such lists always do
towards the end of 2007 ravallo already
dubious about the presumptions behind
the strategy began to look for data that
would reveal whether or not the strategy
worked he found it in the cigarettes
would with full access to the database
revolo extracted the records of 200
cases in which high-value targets had
been killed or captured between june and
october 2007.
then he went through the records again
to see what had happened in the
neighborhood where each leader had where
each leader had operated this was the
crucial question
had his elimination made a difference in
the fight against the insurgents
revolo counted the number of ied attacks
against americans in the 30 days
following each high-value target death
or arrest within a given distance from
the event and compared it to the number
in the 30 days before the death or
arrest as a percentage of change
repeating this procedure for different
distances rivallo plotted the results on
one axis of a graph and the distance on
another
on the other when complete the graph
delivered a simple unequivocal message
the strategy was indeed making a
difference but not the one intended
hitting hvis did not reduce attacks and
save american lives it increased them
each killing had quickly prompted mayhem
within three kilometers of the target's
base of operation attacks over the
following 30 days shot up by 40
within a radius of 5 kilometers a
typical area of operations for an
insurgent cell they were still up 20
percent
summarizing his findings for odiona
rivallo added an emphatic punchline
conclusion hvi's strategy our principal
strategy in iraq is counterproductive
and needs to be reevaluated
how could the removal of from the scene
of ringleaders of attacks on american
gen americans generate such a
counter-intuitive result
just as the field officers have told
hickey and rivallo during their 2005
trip
dead leaders were invariably replaced
quickly usually in 24 hours always in
48.
for a variety of reasons new commanders
were almost always eager to press the
fight harder
often they would be relatives of the
dead man and hop for revenge
in addition having just succeeded to the
command they would feel the need to
prove themselves especially if the late
leader's martial energies had been
faltering due to battle fatigue or other
interest
highlighting the need for a new broom
always they were more deadly
a week after submitting his findings
rivallo asked odione if he'd read their
study yeah replied the powerful
commander shortly there's a limit to
what i can do
bureau bureaucratic politics it seemed
superseded empirical truth
so
sir
there's a non-military none uh
a non-military
non-international question
if you think back years ago people
worried about the proliferation of
handguns now people on the streets have
ak-47s and automatic weapons and all
kinds of things
and i already read that drones are being
used they talk about delivering packages
about
farmers using them about photographers
using them
will we
in the near future soon have
drones being used by uh
let's say hit met professional hit men
by by
various drug groups who fight against
each other is that going to be the
inevitable result of all this
well it's possible i mean already
there's been been efforts to smuggle uh
drugs across the mexican border although
it turns out they they keep crashing i
mean so i stress a lot the drones are
kind of unreliable so they uh the the
border area and uh between uh
uh uh mexico and the us is apparently
littered with sort of you know if you
want some help yourself to some crystal
meth or something head down there
yes of course it could be you know we
had the case the other day of a a drunk
intelligence agency who decided to fly
his friend's drone at 3 a.m
and flew it over the white house and
then it crashed into a tree so it's um
you know this is all made possible by
gps which is the essential thing that
makes all you know has made drone
warfare really possible um and
you know the technology really isn't
even that esoteric
so yeah it's going to happen i will say
that you know people worry a lot about
other countries you know mounting drone
attacks on us i'll say at least for the
moment i don't think any other country
has the kind of global
commander control system that we've
built up a staggering cost um that sort
of
you know
enables them to run drone operations on
the other side of the world
which is you know very sort of
complicated business and extremely
expensive so
i think there's lots of other things we
can worry about in the meantime
hi thank you so much for your book it
was very um i've just started reading it
and it's really very very illuminating
and interesting i had two questions
actually unrelated but um the first one
is i'm wondering i wanted to get a
sharper sense of your critique it seems
to me that there are two critiques that
one can make around drones
one critique is the one about
technological failure right the one that
says you know they actually can't see as
clearly as they claim they're killing
too many civilians etc and that is a
critique that seems to me that can you
know we need more transparency we need
more accountability and that's a
critique it seems to me that can sit
very comfortably within american empire
that is to make an empire more efficient
right and then so and and the other
critique is one that you know is more
about a moral political
principle which is let's assume these
things work at top form
let's assume that um you know they can
actually see quite well
and they don't kill civilians
does the united i mean does the you know
is it okay then for drones to be used is
you know
it seems to me like we
tend to not question
the sort of politics of this issue and
the reason i ask that question is
because
i have spoken with survivors of these
attacks and when i've spoken with them
they're not talking about accountability
and transparency they're talking about
wanting these attacks to end and
querying the sort of
logic by which the us app you know
allows itself to gives itself the right
to attack so i'm wondering if you could
talk a little bit about sort of where
you place yourself in that well i mean
the thing is i mean you have to ask
yourself i mean give the
i mean they do work you know they do
work a lot of the time i don't want to
make it's
not i'm not trying to say that they
always fly fail and fall out of the sky
i mean you have to ask why you know why
it is we pursue why it was when um that
thing that rick read if you were here
rick mcarthur read at the beginning
about you know the report said that this
thing is a technological bust it fails
all the time and yet uh the air force
chief
official was very angry that he you know
the the tester was reporting this
you have to remember it's all about
money i mean people make a huge amount
of money out of this and that's why
you get a very faulty system like this
with all sorts of drawbacks gets fielded
i'll give you one quick example of
the imperatives the um the drone lobby
got a few years ago got the congress to
tell the border patrol
to buy made them put in an appropriation
for them to buy six reaper drones
which they uh so they duly flew them and
indeed they detected lots of um
something like five thousand little over
five thousand illegal border crosses uh
many
including drug mules
then some subversive person however some
subversive official rented a cessna
plane
and equipped it with a simple infrared
scope and a telescope and then flew that
on the same routes for the same amount
of time and that caught 50 percent more
illegal border crossings
and so the further you and the drug
whereas the drones each capture
had cost if you broke it down seven
thousand dollars
the uh cessna's captures cost two
hundred and thirty dollars
so but uh
uh whereupon the there was the
inevitable result which was no cessna
was ever used again and the congress
immediately ordered the border patrol to
buy more drones so it's you know you
have to think about what what really
drives all this and why the decisions
that get made
get made that way um
but let's assume that it worked
okay now it certainly worked well you
know then is it okay i mean no i mean
not because it you know it does work a
lot of the time and as we can see the
results are not you know kind of
interesting um as that last bit i read
jokes i mean i talked about you know the
whole idea of high value targeting um
you know those are all those hundreds of
successful missions where they've taken
out you know mr big here and there um
and what does the result be
not you know victory i mean we've gone
this has been our principal weapon
um
you know the occasional dips into sort
of airsoft anthropology with the coin
program and all that um but there's been
our principal weapon in these wars on
terror the um
[Music]
so the uh and the result has been you
know in 2001 al qaeda
were a bunch of ruffians living in
muslim hiding in caves uh you know on
the in afghanistan um you know that was
a famous video which was used to scare
us all showing al-qaeda training in fact
when they did that when they al-qaeda
made that video they had so few people
they'd had to rent a neighboring tribe
to come in and play terrorist
now
uh we have mr al baghdadi the caliph
presiding over an area the size of texas
uh with millions of inhabitants and
recruits thousands of recruits streaming
in every week and you know with branch
operations starting up ourselves
elsewhere that's a you know you can say
that's a result of the successful drone
and you know other things we've done um
so there's that you know and the other
sort of down product of when it works
you know when it works i mean those
those drones that you know you can hear
all the time in the air above the uh you
know above the
relevant areas in waziristan or yemen
southern yemen or the
parts of yemen um somalia
gaza to name another flourishing drone
operation um
they're they're all working that's all
going fine but the result as i said are
is traumatized society and you know
a huge
whatever possibility you've had of
reconciling the inhabitants domitius
diminishes sharply
so fred
so andrew do you identify a turning
point here because you remember until
about 2007
the air force the air force chiefs
weren't wild about drones at all
uh you know when gates became secretary
of defense
he wanted to order more drones because
every ground commander in iraq was
saying i need more groans drones and
just for reconnaissance to see where all
the ied planters were going and the air
force chief of staff
you know just didn't buy them he forced
them to buy them they they wouldn't
deploy them you know the air force chief
of staff and the secretary of the air
force were
fired mainly because
they were resistant on on getting drones
i mean the cover story was that nuclear
accident but that's really all it was
but
was there something i mean what was it
um
was it a kind of a generational thing a
new kind of air force officer come along
i mean the air force chief of staff was
replaced by the guy who'd been the
commander of transportation command
who'd been with special forces i mean
was that it or was
i mean
what was going on politically or
bureaucratically that kind of changed
the whole dynamic well it goes waves i
mean the chief of staff who got barred
you're talking about general mosley
he didn't like drones but his
predecessor general jumper was mad keen
on drones um
and he'd actually bought lots of them so
you know it's different
different constituencies in the air
force come and go i'd say the turning
point really
um i would say was in 2008
um
when uh general hayden as director of
the cia
went to the white house went to see bush
um and he was egged on by this other
scary character who is the head of the
counter-terrorism center who's plays a
hugely important role in all this um
and said to bush you know we you know
al-qaeda is massing they're they're
they're regrouping they're about to come
at us again and scare the daylights out
of bush and got authorization
to loosen the restrictions on drone
targeting um
and so um
you know after then it's been uh you
know to give bush credit that had been
they've been failures you had to
absolutely know you were trying to hit
you had to be absolutely sure of where
he was who he was and all the rest and
hayden this was in july 2008
hayden got um
got bush to sort of relax that and now
they were allowed to
attack people
who are those who whose identities were
unknown they were just behaving they
were just looking guilty
so for instance within a short space of
time armed men in a truck heading
towards afghanistan qualified as
terrorist targets and could be hit
and this was the infamous signature
strikes uh yes
gates faced opposition from the people
he derided as fly boys and silk scarves
but gates was
very comparatively speaking of forceful
secretary defense
and you know did ramp up the uh thing
and once you know once there was money
about once he was prepared to sort of
put your resources behind it you know
suddenly there was a big big change of
opinion in the air force i mean they you
know there's always
either there was at that time there's
another factor you have to bear in mind
which is you know it's all about money
and the air force was thinking there was
other things they could build which were
more expensive you know um
more attractive the uh these boss you
know the f-35 fighter which is
costing now is up to sort of uh
probably 400 million dollars a copy uh
various transport planes and i should
jumping forward again straying off the
point for a second
drones you now find uh the main the big
manufacturers getting more interested in
drones because now you have 304 300 and
400 million dollar drones which makes
them more attractive
[Music]
to
to the industry so you know it it does
um it does escalate and there are shifts
but i would say 2008 and then when obama
comes in
um
and he has brennan by his side finishing
his sentences and finishing each other's
sentences
um they're really off the races because
there was other decisions came into play
where you know obama was pledged to
abolish guantanamo and they didn't
really want to capture terrorists
anymore they thought it was easier to
kill them um
that lent an incentive so um
but i said it's it's uh um
i also would like to say quickly that i
don't you know this isn't all about
drones this idea of picking off critical
nodes of uh you know dis dismantling the
enemy machine machine by war machine by
hitting specific targets goes back a
long way back into world war ii it never
works it's never worked it's always
pursued it was pursued in vietnam
to uh i
have an early chapter about describing
an attempted remote control warfare in
vietnam which
didn't work um it was pursued in the
both the in the first iraq war where
they endlessly thought tried to sort of
kill saddam
and failed um drones made all this more
attractive it seemed to make all this
easier and they pursued it then but it's
as i say yeah i mean there's different
you have to do the politics or there's
always political bureaucratic politics
going on but the uh
if you want a turning point i'd say
2008.
anyone else
i'm not sure how long i've been talking
it's all gone by in a blink of an eye so
anyway thank you all for coming
and i hope you like the book
[Applause]
too many years
blessings